how many of you have ever had an idea
for business or a product but you were
just too scared to go for it
because starting your own company is not
easy it's the most intimidating thing
and this year has been especially not
incentivizing and
tough on small businesses and that's why
our show
loves highlighting them so now it's time
for another edition of
small business challenge
oh thank you okay in this challenge two
entrepreneurs face off to win a prize
package that will help
take their company to the next level
today we have two companies and they
both are already featured
on our little book of small businesses
take a look
hi i'm jasmine this is justin we're
husband and wife team and the owners and
co-founders of morningjoyco
at morningjoyco we make laser engraved
recipe cutting boards
you can send an old family recipe and
we'll engrave the exact handwriting on a
cutting board
we started our business in april 2020
and almost immediately felt like we were
onto something
we started hearing feedback from our
customers that our products were special
and over and over again we hear the same
story
these are perfect gifts to preserve
cherished memories
our dream is to keep growing the
business we want to expand our products
create a website and invest in upgraded
equipment thank you drew and to all of
you for supporting small businesses like
ours
we're so excited for what's to come hi
i'm tamara owner and founder of queen
bee jelly monarch fabrics
quinby jelly modern fabrics is an online
fabric boutique
specializing in ankara which is a
african fabric because the fabric is
so beautiful i would love to see it
in hotels used for upholsteries
maybe headboards and draperies pillows
or even in schools so i realized my
purpose
is to inspire others and that's what i
built queen bee jelly off of
all right to get this started i'm so
excited i want to welcome
my co-judge he is a businessman investor
author motivational speaker and one of
the stars
of abc's shark tank it's my favorite
show
please welcome damon john
[Music]
oh my goodness i can't believe i'm
sitting here
thank you for coming as you can see we
haven't had that many people come out i
looked that way i didn't know where you
were coming from
it's amazing this is the first time i've
been out okay i am the
biggest shark tank fan i'm sure you hear
that all the time
i can't hear it enough i really
appreciate it well it's just such a
genius
show for those who love inventions for
those who love business and i am
obsessed with business
speaking of business i mean your company
fubu has over
6 billion would they be
in sales and you started out in your
mother's
house in queens and then turned it into
a global empire i can't think of anyone
to talk about
building a business with yeah it was
tough but thank god and i think that's
what everybody loves about shark tank
they see
everyday people that just get up off the
couch and they make it happen
well i like hearing you say that because
we talked about some of the fear that
goes into taking that leap of faith
you know giving up security going for
the dream it's terrifying and you meet
budding entrepreneurs every single day
in the 12 seasons
that you've done you've made over 80
deals and
for this segment i want to get right to
what are you
looking for in pitches which i'm just
excited as a viewer also
to know well you know i'm generally
looking for the fact that they have
they have what we call proof of concept
they've sold to somebody it doesn't have
to be a massive amount
um and often because my money personally
and
you know today is not necessarily the
same situation i look to see if i like
the person
um in business whether you are trying to
apply for a job with somebody or whether
you're trying to get an investment
people just have to like you they want
to know they can sit next to you
forever so are you ready today for this
small business challenge i am i'm ready
okay i can't i'm freaking out all right
let's meet our entrepreneurs please
welcome justin and jasmine allrad
the owners of morningjoycon
[Applause]
love your products love featuring you on
our small business guide thank you for
joining and
tamara walker the owner of queen bee
jelly
hi
um i'm such a fan of both of your
businesses
i can't believe i'm getting to do this
with damon um
would you guys like to know what you're
competing for today yes oh my gosh
all right let's take a look the winner
of today's small business challenge will
receive a marketing package
which includes a feature on the home
page of our show's website
a consultation with award-winning pr
executive susan mcgreno
who's worked with clients such as martha
stewart cuisinart
virgin atlantic and coach and to top it
off
today's winner will receive 10 000
from bill.com the leading payment
software company
and the runner-up won't go home
empty-handed they will also receive
1 000
thank you guys really we're so excited
to do this with you
and are you ready first up justin and
jasmine what is your pitch
why should you win hi i'm jasmine this
is justin we are the owners and
co-founders of morningjoyco
we make custom engraved cutting boards
most popularly we engrave original
handwritten recipes as keepsakes
we started our business after trying to
start our family and finding out we were
unable to have biological children
we still wanted to create a legacy and
make something beautiful together
and so morningjoyco was born what makes
us unique is our personalized customer
experience
with step-by-step communication from
first draft to final product
it creates a personal connection with
each of our customers which has provided
us
1400 cells and over 400 reviews in the
last
year starting our business every single
review has been five-star
um we also plan to expand our products
and invest in better equipment and if we
win this
amazing competition um we hope to be
able to reach closer to our goals
um drew and damon we just wanted to say
thank you so much thank you
for this opportunity uh i'm just honored
to do it with everyone here in this room
and damon i want to throw it to you
do you have a question for justin
jasmine yes so so i love hearing about
the reviews
um he says 400 reviews did you have say
he had 1400
sales yeah we started our business on
april 4th
and last year yeah last year to the date
over 1400 sales
yeah in total uh units right uh more
units some people will order make an
order we've had as much as 11 boards on
a single order sorry
have you sold any retailers at all no no
okay perfect yeah
[Music]
okay
you